hey everyone this is Steve [__] with
collider and I'm here at our Sundance
studio in Park City uh I want to give a
huge thank you before we get started to
filo for being our sponsor uh here at
Sundance and helping to support
independent cinema uh without them we
wouldn't be here this year and I'm I'm
really sincerely grateful uh if you're
not familiar with the film. which is
behind us uh they are shattering
barriers by placing the power to greenl
films in the hands of creators and fans
uh you can learn a lot more about uh
film. by going to the website and on
that note how are you guys
doing I we're I think we're all doing
pretty damn good I now I'm really
interested about
film reason being because you know we're
in music you're in film but so how do
the how do the fans or the audience get
these projects screen Ed cuz you see
where I'm going here oh 100% And I
listen uh I and I really mean this
sincerely it is very expensive to come
to Sundance and cover and support
Independent films because Park city is
just a really expensive place and
without
film. or filme EO like we really
wouldn't be here this year um and I want
to open that door but I also want to
talk about La laaloa so bad so I will
just say that right um for people that
want to learn more the website's there
and also when this interview is over
people from filo are here and they can
absolutely answer your questions and uh
I I'm only trying to you know promote
you know what I mean we got you exactly
so uh I have a bunch of questions but I
like throwing some curve balls at the
beginning you have an amazing resume of
Music if someone hypothetically has
never heard any songs that you have done
what is the first one you'd like them
starting with and
why I I would probably change the answer
daily right but um last night as an
example there was a gentleman and he was
told me he was
56 um and he said you know your song
Jane
says meant a lot to me he said it still
does mean a lot to me and I understood
what what he meant you know
and just to know that there was a song
when a person needed a song like that
when they're at their worst or at their
lowest you know the only thing I could
think of other than like the top surgeon
in the world would be the top musician
in the world to heal his broken heart
you know first of all that song is like
one of my favorites that you've done but
second of all it it has I can't imagine
what it's like for you to have created
works of art music is works of art that
has impacted people on just a daily
basis and they go to it to make
themselves feel good or to you know what
I mean it must be an amazing feeling
it's like being a
vitamin that's an interesting analogy
and very
true so I like walking around town
feeling like a vitamin um so listen I I
I want for everyone um I'm so happy you
made this and the first two episodes
were fantastic but I am so I'm so ious
how did you decide it's ultimately three
episode series yes so how did you decide
it was going to be a three episode
series did you know that going in or was
it based on you know the footage you had
and the story you wanted to tell yeah
I'll take a swing at this I mean the
truth of the matter is is a really hard
decision and there's a version that is
you know 300 episodes of this we had
mountains and mountains and mountains of
incredible footage um we wanted to make
sure that the film explored all the
topics that we explored and we wanted to
make sure sure that it did that um at a
at a Brisk pace and we didn't want to be
too luxurious in it but honestly it was
one of the harder decisions of the whole
project for me personally was how to let
go of some of the some of the storylines
I we had to let go of in order to make
this film um the way we knew it should
be made and for people listen I I
realize most people watching this will
have not seen the show yet the docu
series so who wants to bite the bullet
and explain do the log line of what it's
about and what what people can look
forward to well this Lala the story of
laa pla is um just in a in the nutshell
is it's the story of the entire history
of laa ploa which started in 1991 and
started as James addiction Perry and and
the band it was supposed to be their
farewell tour and they brought together
acts that weren't playing big venues but
together as a as a force as the the
entire lineup that they had they were
able to play these larger shows and were
a traveling f FAL which festivals had
been dead in America since ultimat in
the 1960s so they do this Festival it
actually is a huge success and what it
does is it does exactly what you would
hope something like does it brings the
underground up from being the
underground to like actually people
experiencing art in a way they had never
experienced it before and Perry had the
foresight to continue to break these new
bands these new acts these new artists
in ways that nobody had ever done before
and it carries through all the way to
today Perry can one of the things I
think a lot of people will not realize
uh or will forget is when you put this
together this was before the internet
and this and one of the things that I
think that a lot of people in fact the
year Lala broke the internet
broke well I I want to it was that year
I want to specifically talk about the
fact that one of the things that I
thought was so amazing that you did with
the festival and do with the festival is
highlighting groups like whether it be
you know the right to vote or paa or
whatever the groups are you can be
specific but having them at a festival
like that and you were exposing these
groups and um to people that might not
normally get it in different parts of
the country because again before the
internet you well you know it presented
um some challenges obviously but it also
did some things that you know I'll give
you an example
you ever show up at a party and uh it
wasn't supposed to be a very big deal
but it ended up might have been 25
people there not a super overcrowded
party wasn't overhyped but then you were
there and like you started meeting these
really interesting
people and they they knew the music to
play that you know they knew the the the
discussions to have and then you end up
thinking
back on that night and you're going like
God that was one of like my favorite
nights
but you know and it was it was uh I I
couldn't have almost
afforded all the the richness of that
night so what was beautiful about what
we had to do is we had to work with the
fact that there was no easy cell we
couldn't Ram it down your throat it had
to be word of mouth so it had to be the
right people and I always say the best
parties they're always
generated by people that know great
music draw those people that love great
music they become your friends and they
become part of then then that becomes
the culture so that
handicap actually did great things for
us because it wasn't easy to find it was
out of the way so when you found it that
was the great feeling one of the things
I think that uh people don't realize
when you're making a series like this is
you need to clear all the footage and
and the clearing and the clearing of
next question right and the clearing of
the footage is sometimes very
challenging where you can lose things
because you can't clear it so did you
end up talk a little bit about the
challenges of clearing and was there
stuff that you are so disappointed you
couldn't do because you ultimately
couldn't clear it we were incredibly
Lucky in what we were able to clear and
first of all we were incredible L
incredibly Lucky in what we found we had
remarkable footage you s so you've seen
it right it's sort of like an onslaught
it just keeps coming at you with I can't
even believe we have this on camera and
that it's in this movie now so we were
enormously successful in finding stuff
and enorm enormously successful in being
able to clear it but yes of course there
are challenges with all that um what we
couldn't like the shot I couldn't clear
that I really missed was that Trent
resner 9in Nails performance where he's
like crawling like an inm across the
stage covered in dust when he has that
Big Show after you know no spoilers but
he's having a great performance um that
there was another camera that we
couldn't we that we couldn't clear yeah
and so it was just so beautiful but we
we had all this other incredible stuff
so like no one's ever going to miss that
thing that we couldn't clear um because
that scene last night I was like this
scene's almost it's almost better
without it because it was so well edited
um and so uh it was definitely a
challenge um a lot of people did us a
lot of favors Perry's got a lot of
Goodwill out in the world um and and and
I think a lot of the people who were
holding on to that footage understood
that if you're this is the moment to let
us use this footage and so people did us
a lot of favors we had an incredibly
talented uh group of people working on
it um so one one of the things I was
thinking about as I was watching laala
paloa is I was comparing it to Sundance
a little bit because and and let me go
with this and I normally it's a little
might be an extended question or
statement whatever like with Sundance
Sundance do an amazing job championing
uh independent cinema but they surround
it with like big stars in smaller movies
and with laal LA paloa there's a lot of
like smaller bands But ultimately like
you have to have I think someone at the
top or there has to be a band for some
people like they know they're going to
get that but they're also going to get
all these other cool acts so can you
sort of talk about was that ever in your
in the beginning stages in the first few
years can you sort of talk about that or
as the festival has grown that like you
do do you know what I mean like it's the
mixture of Indie and a little bit of
popularity and that that Melting Pot is
allows you to do these things there's a
b there's a balancing act for sure um
and in the end I think we we make a
pretty good team there are people
working
analytics I'm not one of them I go you
know nice thing is I still go by my
heart and by my ears if you know if I
can hear something that turns me on then
I'm certain it's going to turn other
people on doesn't matter if 10 people
know about them yet but I know I can
hear they should know about him and when
they know when they know about him when
they hear him when they see him again
they'll never forget it can you bu all
talk about why was why is now the right
time to tell the story and not say 10
years ago or not you know what I mean
like what is it about this moment can I
take this one this is your favorite one
to I love this question okay so uh I was
a I was a 17 years old in 1991 and I saw
the first La of pla but prior to seeing
that I was sort of stuck in the the
doldrums of suburban America
um we were seeing a lot of tur you know
turbulent times at that moment there was
this ultraconservative movement going on
in America we were watching the
environment start to really Catch Fire
uh the realities of P police brutality
had come into headlines with the Rodney
King video was which was eye- opening
for those of us who didn't live in a
city um and uh me and my weird little
artist friends were pissed as hell about
what was going on but we thought we were
alone on that and so I went to pla to
see one of my heroes Perry and all the
other incredible bands that were on that
bill um and suddenly I see these
activist booths and I see these kids
moshing and Stage diving like I had seen
that but I saw it at the VFW Hall in my
hometown with like 30 people in the
audience Suddenly It's thousands of kids
doing it and I knew if there's thousands
of kids in Mansfield Massachusetts oh
you went to Great Woods yeah I'm from
Mansfield Massachusetts believe it or
not we we'll get there in a second but I
knew if there were thous thousands of we
won't get there in a second
um I knew if there were thousands of
kids in my hometown who felt like I did
and were that pissed off then that meant
there were millions of us across America
and I think that la la ploa sort of
pulled us all into one room and we all
were like holy [__] we're we are all
feeling this way and I really feel like
Gen X was um identified that day and and
so um it it was just this moment and
then I also feel like um one of the
reasons why this film is so important
right now is I feel like gen Z is going
through a lot of the same things we were
going through back then with the Supreme
Court and Clarence Thomas like it's
insane the environment police brutality
it's all these same things that are
hitting right now and so last night at
the at our screening a bunch of gen Z
kids came up to me and they're like
thank you for making this movie it
really struck a core with me and I said
to them I was like good I'm glad it did
because I feel like you guys are up
against a lot of what we were up against
and maybe you can learn from what we did
right and what we did wrong um so that's
my hope for this series does anyone want
else want to
add well I think that the you know the
illustration of youth culture is it I
can't think of another documentary that
highlights the youth culture over the
course of 30 years and to be able to see
the passion that all of these kids had
when you know when I was a teenager in
the 90s uh wanting to see my favorite
band and discovering new bands which is
like coming the Sundance and discovering
new
filmmakers I didn't you know I I didn't
I never thought about looking back and
seeing Oh there's all these similarities
and you see this growth over the course
of 30 years and that's one of the things
that that became a discovery in making
this series like I don't think we
realize just how impactful it was to be
able to see generation or kids year
after year after year come and celebrate
and look for and discover their favorite
bands you can I add please something to
this
discussion you know when we're growing
up us
boys we like to you know think about oh
you know maybe I'll be a baseball player
or or maybe I'll be a football player
you know you're not big enough to be a
football player or a basketball player
what do I do now you know the the the
World of Sports is there
from the from the earliest age if you
want to be an
athlete the the colleges have you
covered the high schools have you
covered but if you want to be an artist
if you want to be a
musician man you're gonna have a rough
life you can swear you're on you're on
your own and so I I noticed early on I
mean I had the chance to to see this
firstand hand because the generation
before me were driving around in their
own planes you know what I mean it said
Zeppelin on it I'm like [__] man that
sounds like fun right no by the time
James came around you know we were on a
Winnebago you know like drawing you know
dicks on each other's
heads it was a different world you had
to do it because you loved it but the
point I'm trying to make
is there is no system for
artist there's system for
athlete there's not a system for
musician or an or or an artist
so I wanted I wanted to create a system
where you can be 15 years old we'll get
you in a club we get you recording
you're
talented you know what I mean your
artwork is incredible
and and in fact it's raw and it's
truthful because you you you got nothing
to lose because you got nothing so so
tell me the
truth
and I've I've always maintained you know
since
91 that we were that kind of like farm
league bringing up the musicians and and
the artists they're so important because
without them the truth just gets it gets
covered up right away and it and and
again 91 the worldwide web hit it's just
so easy to fool the
public and that tool I think we're going
to get the tool right there's a reason
why our generation got this tool we
we're the right people to deal with it
but we're taking on Monsters we're
taking on people that have no regard for
the environment they just want power and
how they get their
power I mean I don't give a [__] let's
chop down the rainforest right so that
that's who we're up against and the
people that can stop them it sounds
funny like you know musicians should be
wearing superhero costumes
but we take it on we take on the the the
problems of
society and and we also take on you know
we'll party you out too we're invaluable
in that way yeah but
but in the future we will find better
and better systems like what I have a
another project coming up um heaven
after dark and it's um It's All About
Dance music but collaborating with young
dance
musicians and putting on part already's
there we need we need that petri dish
the artist needs that place to grow and
you know it ought to be in schools when
I was a little kid I know they they
allowed me to pick up a trumpet and they
made me give it back but at least there
was music program you know there was
music programs when I was growing up
yeah but there music they're all gone
now and so it's even more difficult to
find those
gems you know you need you need people
like like Lola paloa and you know our
team that care and love and understand
the
importance of how the value it is so
valuable to have a perspective of an
artist and a
musician without
it I mean I was about to just make a
joke that would be just too easy to make
you all laugh but without it the world
would just be just ugly sound that's why
I love this film the series is because I
feel like what he just said is
articulated so well on it and it's
documented and now everyone could go
find that and see that struggle yeah I I
think that uh I didn't think I was going
to bring up Taylor Swift in this but I
thank Taylor Swift for how many people
she has registered to vote on her tour I
mean I think she's registered like a
million people that's awesome yeah
exactly and by the way like I I really
appreciate because musicians really can
influence especially a lot of younger
people you know and you were talking
about and I think about everything
you've done for generations with laala
paloa and how many people you've
influenced and impacted and I'm I say
thank you thank you well I I um I love
all that but I love just as much the
idea that yeah we gave them Sun we gave
them light now the now the world knows
who they are you know they've partied to
them they know they know they know what
they're about and there's your
culture it's it's in the art it's in the
music that's where culture is it
literally is like the Petry dish there's
culture there there's culture oh man
love it great answer as usual I was
going to say that uh um I have a lot of
questions but I'm basically out of time
I'm just going to ask this I think this
might be my last question uh laala
palooza has put on such amazing artists
through the years and I'm curious do all
of you have a favorite year of the
festival and the lineup or is it sort of
like you know what I mean like was there
one year and I'm I think more for you
was there one year you're like I can't
[__] believe this was our
lineup you know um if you showed me if
you showed me a page I I would go like
the other day darling and
when we were talking about all those
people were on that same year and and it
wasn't even a year that anybody like
really talks a lot about do you remember
that what
year okay Muse
Eminem Arctic
Monkeys was it dead
mouse already that's a crazy line like
like there they are they're all there
man out out in the field all we got to
do is kick back and
listen can you believe all that Talent
was there and be but it becomes harder
and harder every year because what we
fight is we fight that internet that
internet threatens to drown us
out so we need to be always I always say
this team we need to be unified we need
to be really strong
because you know money the only way to
beat money is music and
art that's it on that note I need to
wrap with you guys I'm just going to say
and I really mean this this is really
really fantastic uh two I've seen two of
the episodes and obviously as soon as
you want to send me the third I'll watch
but first two episodes are fantastic and
um you guys did a great job and I really
hope it's a huge hit for you guys and
people watch you so much it'll be
Paramount plus uh soon very soon all
three episodes across the globe uh yeah
and that's actually also really cool
about streaming it's it's all over you
know on that note have a fantastic
Sundance thank you so much for com
thanks for having
us